well so can you considering these double
standards i want to talk about this
video that's going viral we have the
story from the daily mail
quote they called me an effing terrorist
moment
burley pro-trump protester saabs at dc
airport after finding out he's been put
on a no-fly list i want to play this
video first
i'm not entirely sure that's true
there's no fly list but let's play so
you can you can
you can hear one of you but this is
so this is just a video right there's a
guy walking away you heard what he said
basically that quote they're calling me
an effing terrorist i heard that it
might actually be that he wouldn't wear
a mask
and people are assuming it has something
to do with what happened at the capitol
and that he's angry they're calling me a
terrorist because he's not wearing a
mask right
maybe but we know that alaska alaskan
airlines did
put 14 people on the no-fly list and
there's been some discussion around this
but man when i saw that video this is a
middle-aged guy he's burly he's not some
like dinky little you know scrawny
individual
whiny little soyboy or whatever you want
to call it he is a
whiny big trump supporter and so i
wonder
when you see this this defeat this
desperation this exasperation
that's uh i'm i'm actually kind of
worried about hearing the kind of
emotion coming from people because
you know i was thinking about just what
they teach you in terms of cornering a
scared animal
right it might be a rabbit but you back
into a corner i think will attack you
you know so you get a bunch of trump
supporters you put them on no fly lists
you beat them down they've been defeated
and now what happens they go after them
with the full weight full force of the
government
threatening you know oh maybe there'll
be felony murder charges for anybody
who's there next
maybe maybe now if you're a musician
we're going to kick you off your label
simply for listening to trump speak and
then going home
maybe we'll cancel your book deals we'll
kick you out of congress they are
beating down these people so hard you're
going to get a bunch of desperate
angry and and just exhausted individuals
who just don't care anymore yeah and
that's when it gets scary when when you
look at the history of the no-fly list
it came after yet another emergency that
the government
milked that of course was 911 and that
system was used and abused where people
with the same names
babies people who had nothing to do with
anyone or anything were literally told
that they couldn't fly
and the their way of having any regress
or any way to have any accountability or
get the name off of this no-fly list was
virtually impossible
this happened for many years so seeing
this now implemented politically
i mean if you're going to charge someone
charge someone what's the purpose of
banning them from flying home or being
home
or even just transporting or going from
place a to b
what's the point what's going on here we
need more information
if they did something wrong charge them
let's let's get this over with
stop messing with them and toying with
them and trying to also
and i think another reason they're doing
this and we're seeing a lot of videos of
people being arrested at airports is to
set a chilling effect is to scare people
is to make people think well maybe if
i'm a trump supporter this is going to
happen to me as well
and that's that's something that should
be immediately called out because just
like the no fly list was used and abused
after 9 11
with muslims and other innocent people
it's being it's going to be used and
abused
uh with the new kind of patriarch 2.0
that they're proposing
that they're going to be instituting and
yet again government's going to be
exploiting another
tragedy another emergency for powers
that they will never give back and this
is the double standard there i have two
points to make
the the first point is you have governor
ralph north
ralph uh northam you have um
bird what what is his
change their their thinking on all these
things right
they're allowed to be redeemed because
they have a d next to their name
all right but when you have when you
have a man who
i i again context is everything here
yeah we don't know if it
had to do with a mask or or whatever
right
but if you're if you're just a normal
person who likes trump
has a trump hat and then somebody says
suddenly oh you're
you're a bad person we're going to fire
you from your job we're gonna
delete your your facebook account we're
going to
uh get you fired we're gonna put you on
no fly list
now let's say that that person is a
racist right and all those things happen
does them getting fired and getting
basically canceled
make them less racist or more racist do
you think they're going to become more
racist
they're going to become more angry right
and the same thing with
with this poor trump supporter i mean
that just hearing that audio
and not knowing the whole context it's
heartbreaking
that that man is in pain yeah and we
don't know why
and if it's something stupid just like
like ariel pink
the the record art the musician who just
went to a trump rally he likes trump
there's things you you're
there's things you're allowed to like
trump for well not anymore because if
you do
you're labeled all these things abraham
accords completely racist
you know what i mean he's he did some
great things
you know when you talk about um uh
the the opportunity zones those are good
things
right but then you know you you can say
look
it's like ben shapiro says there's good
trump and there's bad trump when
when trump does good things we praise
him for when he does bad things
we go after him for it and i agree 100
and we should do that
to biden yeah but but just going after
people just
just trying to completely ruin their
lives just because
they like a guy who's who's absolutely
flawed
is incredibly scary think about where we
go
in the next several years and this is
what i think republicans are too stupid
to realize mitch mcconnell talk about
dumb
does what do you think is going to
happen in 2024 when any republican tries
running any any one of them
no matter who it is they're going to
scream nutsy
and they're going to say it's trump 2.0
no matter what they called bush
a nazi i remember seeing the protest
signs it is
what was is it true that they've equated
like every republican candidate
going back like 40 50 years they've he's
been called a nazi or a fascist
oh yeah they called they called george
bush a nazi they called ronald reagan a
nazi
right right right ronald reagan a nazi
so
you know spare me your indignation
democrats because it's all the game well
it's
all you look at how bad things are now
come 2024
the the republican candidate is not
going to stand a chance they're going to
be completely obliterated it'll be
it'll be trump the fake news and hoaxes
about trump tenfold
it depends hmm well he well it depends
we're only looking i'm sorry we're only
looking at we're we're looking
at it from like one angle which is
biden's popular now biden won and then
whoever runs in 2024
you know uh is going to be running
against him maybe not
because because first of all do you
think that joe biden
is going to be campaigning for a second
term
he didn't campaign this time around
right but he's not going to but he's not
going to have an excuse unless there's
like another global pandemic all right
and and and if he steps down
anybody could beat harris i tim could be
here and well tim
tim's definitely a smarter guy than you
know and better you know a better skater
well i'm glad i agree with tim mainly
because when you control the
institutions of information
mainstream media social media you pretty
much control what people can and cannot
hear
that's unlimited power that essentially
sets them in
a position that can't be challenged you
think you don't think that people
are gonna see what's happening right now
and totally be motivated how will they
see what's happening now
when the mainstream media is advocating
for all forms of competition to be
removed
once big tech companies are removing
these videos people who had photos from
the capitol not even like like from dc
not even the capital
are having those photos removed memes
making fun of this year are being
removed
sure okay but but as long as you tried
banning memes
did you hear this yes that was a lot but
but as far as policy goes
you're going to have you're going to
have all these states that are going to
be
uh their their their citizens are going
to be freaking out
about second amendment rights because uh
when kamala was running
first she said she was going to do a an
executive order about
about guns and it's like joe biden just
like no you can't do that
then she said well i'm going to put let
i want congress to bring up legislation
in the first hundred days
and if they don't then i'm going to do
this right so with
a c with congress in democratic control
now you can see these things happen you
can see
you can see uh a push for there there's
a push forward for
um getting rid of the electoral college
there's a push for
puerto rico and uh washington dc to
become a state
i don't know about guam but i mean they
might as well two more senators why not
let's have six senators
all right so all these things are gonna
happen and people are gonna be like what
whether or not they can
tweet about it or parlay about it i
don't know if that's the term
that is the term is it really they can
parlay about it but
people are people are going to be upset
and you're going to be mobilized and
2022
remember this warnock raphael warnock
the the superhero sounding uh yes
he do you know do you know when his term
is up
2022. yeah because it's special he
doesn't he doesn't get a full term
because he's
he's uh finishing out johnny isaacson's
term
so maybe georgia will get it together
in two years right and then
look the the people didn't turn out it
was a turnout problem
as michael tracy said the left liberal
monoculture
is merging with the state so when you
look at the suppression
from big tech let's let's let's before
yeah when you look at this oppression uh
from the democrats calling and
advocating for the expulsion of
republicans
like i don't i don't see how we we come
back to this point
when aft after they've already had
control of everything you know what i
mean like
part of the reason they lost in georgia
was stacey abrams getting this consent
decree from the governor
a democrat filed a suit they had a
consent decree
it changed the rules without the state
legislature and other rules are changed
and it
heavily favors democrats and it's and
again turnout did affect
republicans but do you think republicans
are going to get more organized as the
tools for organization are stripped away
well we didn't have
i i think that maybe uh
people are going to be turning to you
know alternate ways to
mobilize and communicate no by email
just you know people they banned trump's
email list that well
okay that's fine but smoking you can't
you can't you can't do it to everybody
right i mean they can
if you put together an email list
they'll just see
google will be like this person is doing
an email list he's a fascist
you could you could export your emails
and actually have a physical copy of
them and move them to another server
that might take it down
but another thing that i think
personally will happen i think things
will spiral out of control
and this kind of cycle of violence is
going to continue i don't want it to
but i believe that's going to happen
because all the ingredients that created
this situation
they're being added instead of
subtracting from this
cycle and it's only going to get worse
and it's only going to keep spiraling
out of control and i don't want it to
happen i've been warning people you've
been warning people
and and all the signs are on the wall
that this is going to lead to a crazier
i mean with the no fly list what is that
going to achieve other than a chilling
effect other than scaring people and
creating more people on the fringe
now this started just let's talk about
the merits here because this was talked
about
by a flight attendant unit but now it's
being taken up
by house democrats that are talking with
homeland security in special committee
meetings
and and according to some people this
has already been instituted
we're seeing a lot of people being
arrested we're seeing a lot of people
crying
we're gonna see a lot of people who were
milling around didn't do anything bad up
bad caught up in it punished and then
essentially even radicalized even more i
don't want that
to happen there are some bad actors they
do deserve to be dealt with
but when you're dealing with average
people when you're setting up a chilling
effect
when you're censoring people and
stopping them from having speech
you're not showing you have the moral
high ground because when you have the
moral high ground
when you have something that you think
you're you're better or good at
you let that speak for itself you don't
need to squash any kind of dissenting
voices against that
with that kind of authoritarianism with
that kind of unlimited unchecked power
we are truly entering a time where
they're not going to be on
they're not going to be checked and
they're going to use that power for
uh for their political enemies i have to
stop you
okay i have to tell you that these
people were monsters
and and this this next image you're
going to see this person needs to be
placed
on the no-fly list look at this look at
this shocking image
of a little old lady smiling bewildered
we're holding her little she's holding a
little thermos and she's holding a
little american flag
i'm sorry man i'm not trying to be mean
to her but she clearly has no idea
what's going on
and then they're like it was an
insurrection yeah i mean there was a
group of people that were bashing cops
and by all means charge them and there
were some doting
old women who were confused and the cops
opened the doors and they're like waving
little flags as they walk in like
there were i mean i i think it depends
on where you know if you were breaking
windows and and
going in that way yeah you're probably
gonna be
uh met with some kind of force but if
you're like grandma's like oh here let
me hold the door open for you man
just open the door yeah and and it's
like and there were people taking
selfies i love on twitter the
indignation like
they were taking selfies that cop got
suspended the cop who took the selfie
but like
what was it what was this crime like if
there was exactly if there was like one
side of the building where it's like
that that building's supposed to be open
right i don't know about the i don't
know i don't know about the capitol
building the chambers
um no they had layers of security that
day making sure people couldn't walk
right but
maybe not the house floor but but there
were definitely there were definitely
some mixed
there was definitely some
miscommunication because some people
were opening doors
others were trying to hold them shut so
there's
and well this is where it gets scary are
they gonna take so so you have a video
where the doors are opened and the cops
are just standing there
yeah and one of the cops says something
to the effect of disagree with it
but agree with your right to protest i
don't know if he says you can disagree
with it but i agree with right to
protest or i disagree with i'm not sure
exactly what he says there's been
different quotes from different people
but there are a bunch of people just
walking you know
slowly and like your little flags and
then the cops are just standing there
and they're like nodding walking within
the ropes
yep staying within the ropes as they
walk through and then there were some
people that smashed that bookcase with
like that famous literature that was on
it yeah sure i'm so sure that there was
like
women's historical literature on that
well and that's one
i think that got knocked over because
they broke the window to get in because
yeah and then they burned up the muscle
and it probably knocked it over but you
know to get into those buildings though
you
you do need to go through security right
you do need to uh
you know i went a year and a half ago
and and
you know it's it's not like the toughest
security ever but
they you know they they wand you and
they check your bags and stuff they
clearly we're not doing that i'm sure
you saw what aoc said about it
something like we're seconds away from
half of congress being assassinated yeah
and and by this lady pull it up again
she was coming for aoc
the american flag was actually an
assassin's blade scared
and her little thermos was actually a
spy
uh device for releasing there was a bomb
in it true story
uh but but i asked bombs man this would
be real it was it was dangerous stuff
going on but who knows
who knows where those bombs came from
right there's a video of some dude
dropping them
okay or like walking up well afc saying
that trump
said to storm the house she said that
she said trump said to storm the house
florida yeah
so or or you know i'm paraphrasing but
she said that trump said the storm
you know to go inside and go on the
house where he never said that
no he he said let's go to the capitol
and and
cheer for politicians and cheer and not
cheer for others or something like that
no he he wanted them to like he wanted
the process to play out
he wanted his hearing finally and the
trump supporters who went and shut that
down
i love the yeah thanks guys you had the
live streamers like trump's gonna be
happy with us oh he's gonna be happy
that you disrupted the one time
finally on cnn they would air complaints
and evidence and uh and wow it was the
one
thing that we had and you ruined it it
was the
one thing that's all we had left
and you guys and you guys screwed up
thank you so much this is why i said
this is why i said the last time i was
here that these protest
yes the pro i said that protests don't
do anything i'm
i was wrong protests are only have a
negative effect to the people that are
protesting
right uh i actually had people go oh no
the protest just
yet it just set the tone for the next
four years
trump terrorists trumpism everything
they needed
everything they've been begging for they
they've been sitting in their room lying
awake at night under their covers their
flashlight
wishing just something would happen so
they could prove
everything they said was true for we've
been we've been expecting this for the
last four years
mayor bowser remember that time magazine
i think was time magazine cover of all
the angry trump supporters yelling and
it was like what happens if trump loses
they gave them everything they've been
asking for for four years
trump supporters weren't rioting you
know they weren't smashing windows and
screaming and setting fires no
and they kept saying trump supporters
were dangerous and white supremacy in
the far right and all this
and then finally just before trump
leaves
they had to make sure they left the
administration with they left the
incoming administration
that one day to make all of those past
four years come true
it was it was almost like they're you
know it was almost like they were saying
you know maybe maybe blm had a point
with their well yeah and now let's let's
just
why don't why don't we uh kind of co-op
some of their methods and ideas
louis gomart said this when his lawsuit
was kicked out right he said
and the message is you have to be as
violent as black lives matter or antifa
now the funny thing about that is that
all of a sudden i saw these lefties
these journalists being like
oh no he's inciting violence and i'm
like but i thought those were peaceful
protests
right if they're as violent as the
peaceful protest
they too would be peaceful no and of
course there's all the articles
uh the side-by-side articles like back
from the summer it's like
uh you know violence does have its place
and then they're like you know
now in 2021 it's like violence is never
the answer
have you have you guys seen the most
recent ryan long skit
where it's radical right first
this year we have to admit it i mean
there's even a compilation video of all
the news organizations of all the kind
of left-wing thought thinkers being like
yes we have to excuse it
the ends justify the means and we were
calling it out and it needs to be called
that whether it's from the left or from
the right it doesn't matter
whenever you invoke violence politically
everyone
loses we're all losing right now and
we're going to lose a lot more unless
people
heed the warnings that we're sending out
there and other people are sending out
there because again
one thing we need to also understand
here on this larger point
it's only going to get worse from here i
don't want it to
we have to do everything in our power to
try to prevent it and we're in for a
hell
of a 2021. thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you